[Music]
on this wednesday night the consequences
of a covet explosion
we are approaching a breaking point in
terms of our health care capacity
provinces on the brink consider drastic
measures to prevent their health care
systems from collapsing as the world
junior championships are cancelled
omicron surging in the u.s the new
concerns about new year's eve
celebrations becoming super spreader
events
a stretch of unforgiving cold in the
west goes from frigid it is dangerous
too frightening a flat tire can turn
into a life-altering situation
and the race to help a toronto toddler
with a very rare disease
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us
another day and more unprecedented
numbers in our pandemic once again
quebec has set a new covet 19 record the
province is reporting 13 149
new confirmed cases today that's the
highest daily case count recorded by any
province or territory at any time during
the pandemic ontario also set a record
today with more than ten thousand new
infections the province is also seeing a
jump in hospitalizations and icu
admissions at least five other provinces
and territories have set new single day
highs and those are just confirmed cases
the true number of infections in this
country right now is believed to be much
higher many public health agencies are
struggling to keep up with testing
demands and as abigail beeman explains
the onslaught of omicron is forcing many
provinces and territories to reconsider
their pandemic protocols
at this stage in the pandemic for me
it's
inexcusable
inexcusable to close school says this
icu doctor one of 600 plus to sign this
open letter addressed to ontario's
premier calling for a test to stay
strategy instead using frequent rapid
tests after exposures school closures
had
a tremendous impact on our children on
their
physical health with rising obesity and
even type 2 diabetes their mental health
more anxiety depression their ability to
socialize no decision yet from ontario
while newfoundland announced schools
will return virtually and they're
limiting visits at long-term care homes
this may not be and certainly really
isn't the time to have a really good big
shed party on new year's eve no one is
hospitalized with covet in that province
while in nunavut there are three
hospitalizations and a record 74 cases
the territory is extending its lockdown
and calling for help from ottawa we are
approaching a breaking point in terms of
our health care capacity a breaking
point what quebec is trying to avoid
with its controversial move to let some
essential workers who test positive back
to work as an absolute last resort if
you don't have enough people to keep
your health care system afloat
that would be something that that could
be considered if we are seeing a
quite a substantial strain due to
illness and healthcare system where
we're unable to provide care
uh then then we need to look at these
things we'll certainly do so in the
least
amount of risk possible i don't think we
can completely rule out
uh that if if our hospitals were under
the most extreme kind of pressure
uh that we would have to
modify
the self-isolation requirements allowing
covet-positive people in health care
settings goes hand-in-glove with the
cdc's move to cut isolation periods in
half for most people i think that
ontario uh needs to be smarter doing a
five-day isolation with no back-to-back
testing it's like having your mask below
the nose
it's something also under consideration
in jurisdictions across canada with
workplaces stretched thin by omicron's
extensive reach abigail beeman global
news ottawa
with omicron spreading through players
the international ice hockey federation
is canceling the remainder of the 2022
world juniors in alberta the decision
comes after a coveted positive case on
the russian team which would have meant
a third canceled game in the last two
days chechia and the u.s teams were also
forced to forfeit
late last week the double ihf
preemptively canceled all january events
including the women's under 18 world
championships
in the u.s covet 19 cases have soared to
their highest on record the country is
averaging more than 250 000 new
confirmed cases daily driven by omicron
the centers for disease control say the
variant now accounts for almost 60
percent of all new cases as jennifer
johnson reports there's concern that
number could grow even more because of
new year's eve celebrations
the u.s is reporting another staggering
milestone in the coba 19 pandemic over
53 million americans have been infected
omicron is now the dominant strain
spreading faster than any previous
variant the centers for disease control
is facing backlash after reducing
isolation times for positive
asymptomatic patients from 10 to 5 days
i wish the cdc had also added in are
getting a negative test before ending
isolation complicating the situation a
new study from the food and drug
administration found at home covered 19
tests are less sensitive in detecting
the omicron strain so many people who
get negative results may actually be
positive but it's still picking up quite
a bit of infection but what we would
reiterate is that if you
have a negative antigen test and you
have symptoms then you should go ahead
and get that pcr test the at-home kids
are in high demand as drive-through
sites across the country run out of
rapid and pcr tests at this critical
holiday time we came because we were
family gathering for christmas and one
was very concerned that he had it
healthcare experts are encouraging
americans to reconsider new year's eve
celebrations as medical systems struggle
to keep up with the post-christmas
spread we are really short-staffed right
now over the holidays we work with a
skeleton crew as it is
and then on top of that many of our
healthcare workers are actually out sick
themselves with omicron new york city
continues to go dark the nutcracker
ballet is the latest to cancel all
performances broadway star hugh jackman
has tested positive for covet 19. but
the city school district the nation's
largest says students will return to
classes next week while promising
greater access to those at home tests we
need to keep schools open there are
really high prices that we pay as a
society when children are not in school
the controversial decision comes as
pediatric hospitalizations for cobot 19
are skyrocketing in new york and
increasing twice as fast as adult
hospitalizations across the country
jennifer johnson global news washington
breaking news from new york after a
month-long trial british socialite
elaine maxwell has been convicted of
helping groom teenage girls to be
sexually abused by american millionaire
jeffrey epstein jurors deliberated five
full days before announcing the verdict
today maxwell was found guilty of five
of six counts and faces years in prison
her lawyers said she's being used as a
scapegoat for crimes committed by
epstein he died by suicide in 2019.
china's foreign ministry says relations
with canada stand at a crossroads the
comments come just days after prime
minister justin trudeau accused beijing
of engaging in coercive diplomacy during
a global news year-end interview trudeau
suggested china is using its economic
heft to play democratic countries off
one another the chinese foreign ministry
is now accusing trudeau of
misunderstanding and miscalculating
canada's approach to beijing
in hong kong police raided the largest
pro-democracy news outlet in the city
current and former employees were
arrested and operations at stand news
suspended it comes just six months after
another independent news outlet was shut
down under beijing's new national
security laws redmond shannon reports
hong kong police ordered the deputy
editor of stand news to stop filming
them
their arrival at ransom chan's home was
coordinated with an early morning raid
at the newspaper offices police seized
equipment and documents and say they
arrested seven current and former
employees for conspiracy to publish
seditious publications according to
local media they include board member
and former lawmaker margaret ing and pop
star denise ho a former board member
they are
the evil elements that damage press
freedom hong kong's pro-beijing deputy
leader said these arrests are only about
removing politically biased reporting
these are the bad apples who are abusing
their position simply by wearing a force
coat of media worker the stand news
website now says the paper has ceased
operations it was the largest
pro-democracy news outlet in hong kong
after the raid and closure of apple
daily this year its jailed founder jimmy
lai was served additional sedition
charges just this week ronson chan had
previously expressed his fears stan news
could face the same fate it's not easy
to say that i'm not afraid of the
situation the media crackdown comes
after beijing introduced new national
security laws for hong kong last year
following the 2019 pro-democracy
protests local elections this month saw
representatives only elected from a
beijing-approved list of candidates
these arrests are definitely statements
um warning the others that if you are
keen to do independent media or having
news that are critical towards the
government
that you will pay the price of being
prosecuted exiled campaigner nathan law
says the remaining small pro-democracy
news outlets may be next and also the
government may turn the focus on
foundations and funds that are helping
political christians law fears the
dwindling level of press freedom in hong
kong may soon approach the levels of
mainland china recently deemed the
world's fourth worst by reporters
without borders redmond shannon global
news
a year of extreme weather is ending with
dangerously cold temperatures across
most of the west a deep freeze has
settled over much of b.c alberta
saskatchewan and manitoba the unusually
cold weather is causing all kinds of
problems from frostbite and frozen pipes
to canceled covid clinics heather your
ex west has more
the biting cold has been relentless in
calgary
for several homes and businesses in the
city it's been more than the water lines
could handle over the last several days
our fire crews especially in the
downtown core have been exceptionally
busy with burst pipe calls and water
related calls related to the extreme
cold weather on wednesday extreme cold
warnings remained in place for all of
alberta and much of saskatchewan
manitoba and bc
many regions expecting wind chill values
colder than 40 below it is dangerous
it's dangerous to people it's dangerous
to animals and you can get into trouble
so quickly something like a flat tire
can turn into
a
life-altering situation if you're not
prepared for it for the unhoused the
extreme cold can be life-threatening in
edmonton shelters have had to mobilize
to protect clients not only from the
freezing temperatures but surging
omicron cases as well a lot of people
are
you know have inappropriate outerwear on
or
have been exposed to the elements in
some way so dealing with a lot of
frostbite and
a little bit of you know panic about
trying to get in to get somewhere warm
the cold has impacted the covid fight
too
in bc fraser health says hazardous
weather conditions forced them to reduce
services at 66 covet testing and
immunization centers come in all the way
from maple ridge to coquitlam
just to find out there's a little tiny
sign saying we're closed due to extreme
weather the good news is this deep
freeze isn't expected to last forever
and by the weekend most places across
the west will be experiencing more
moderate temperatures here in calgary
we're expected to hit a balmy high of
minus four by saturday colleen
heather your ex west in calgary heather
thank you
the next phase of canada's she session
coming up how the pandemic has put new
stressors on women in the workforce
former senator and indigenous advocate
murray sinclair is among the 135 new
additions to the order of canada
sinclair who chaired the truth and
reconciliation commission into
residential schools tops the list along
with a popular novelist life of pie
author yan martel is being recognized
for his storytelling and philanthropy
the 2021 honor roll is the first under
mary simon who became governor general
in july
covert 19 has fueled job and income
losses for women more than men and in
canada the so-called she session isn't
over according to employment experts
nearly two years into the global
pandemic it's taking a different toll on
women it's impacted their ability to
hold down a job and progress in their
careers and gaviola explains
the pandemic just keeps hitting melissa
herrod's recently opened axe throwing
business the latest covid surge has
resulted in cancellations and staffing
shortages during what should have been a
busy holiday season
i tested positive on a rapid test and
i'm still waiting for my pcr results i
have been in quarantine for now or in
isolation now for at home for 15 days
with a four-year-old and a
seven-year-old to make everything even
more complicated she doesn't know
whether school will be online or in
person in january
the child care options here are very
very limited there are some after school
programming but to be honest they're
often very hard to get into the first
year of the pandemic disproportionately
hammered women's employment and it took
them a lot longer to recover on the jobs
front according to the latest data women
in their prime working years have mostly
recovered but the numbers don't tell the
whole story
even though employment levels for women
aged 54 and under bounced back close to
pre-pandemic levels this fall the latest
wave of covid restrictions is expected
to impact women workers the hardest
labor market experts say there's a
disconnect between the official stats
and the real impact of nearly two years
of uncertainty and disruption we
actually do see that in the mental
health state where we see an increase in
problems of people reporting depression
and anxiety particularly among moms uh
canada has had one of the highest rates
of school closures certainly in province
like ontario in the world um and that's
really had an impact on family and like
people are on edge right now it's been a
roller coaster so many ups and downs
over the course of the pandemic
jennifer hargreaves runs a recruitment
firm and sees the impact of the ongoing
she session in her line of work the
numbers don't really reflect women's
access to opportunity which i do believe
has been limited throughout the pandemic
and continues to be limited right now
labor analysts say this phase of the she
session may be the most difficult to
quantify and the impact on women's
career trajectories may linger long
after the pandemic
and gaviola global news toronto
app apathy ahead why canadians lost
interest in health canada's covet alert
app
across the country soaring covet 19
cases have forced many public health
officials to give up on contact tracing
instead canadians are being asked to
warn people they've been in contact with
to isolate and monitor for symptoms but
there's another tool available the
federal government's covid alert app but
as david aiken tells us it isn't being
talked about or used anymore
the premise of the covet alert app is
relatively simple when people are near
each other their phones exchange and
record anonymous numeric codes so that
if a person using the app ever became
sick with kovid an alert could be sent
to every phone that came near the phone
of the infected person those alerted can
then get tested or self-isolate but even
though prime minister justin trudeau
often encouraged the use of the app this
is literally a tool in your pocket to
fight this virus
it never really took off british
columbia alberta yukon and nunavut never
signed on and new data provided to
global news shows declining use of the
app through much of the year 6.8 million
of the 30 million smartphones in canada
have the app installed in april nearly 6
500 users punched in the code to say
they were infected that in turn
generated 35 000 notifications to other
app users but by november just 869 users
told their app they were infected and
that generated 11 000 alerts
those numbers declined even though
ottawa had spent 20 million dollars
promoting its use in radio tv and online
ads the covid alert app nonetheless
health canada continued to try improving
the app global news has learned that
earlier this year it considered building
a qr code scanning function into the app
when a user heads into a venue like a
theater or a restaurant a user scans a
qr code posted at the entrance to the
facility then if a covered outbreak is
associated with that venue around the
time of the visit the user is alerted
and takes appropriate health steps
health canada spent seventy four
thousand dollars to hire a consulting
firm to find out what canadians thought
about improving the app this way
sixty percent like the idea nearly half
said it would increase their interest in
the app and about the same thought it
would help contain the spread of the
virus
but provincial health authorities told
health canada they were not interested
and so the idea was dropped so for now
the alert app remains as it is the
government says it will maintain it but
it has neither plans to improve it nor
any plans to get all the provinces to
sign onto the program
david aiken global news ottawa
next the heartfelt plea to help a
toronto toddler battle an ultra rare
genetic disorder with no known treatment
[Music]
a toronto family is issuing a heartfelt
plea taking on the battle of their lives
for the sake of their young daughter the
toddler has an ultra rare genetic
disorder few children in the world have
and right now there's no treatment as
karen lieberman reports every moment in
the search for a cure counts
good job
every step maddie kilner takes and each
smile is a cherished moment etched in
the minds of her mom and dad she's just
the happiest little girl everyone who
meets her is like she's always so happy
all the time and so smiley and you know
so we really tried to focus on that what
started with a single seizure at four
months cam and i were just holding hands
thinking
what is happening to our poor to our
poor little girl has become a
life-altering disease in june of 2021 we
learned that that matty was diagnosed
with
a very rare very serious genetic
disorder called scn8a it causes
severe epilepsy
most of it is drug refractory so
the seizures are likely to come back
it's kind of just a matter of one and it
also causes development delays and a
high likelihood of development
plateauing
the disease gene scn-8a was first
discovered by dr michael hammer in
arizona who identified it in his own
daughter soon after her death in 2011.
you know i as a parent especially as a
scientist you know just was troubled by
the fact that we didn't know what it was
i didn't know if there was another child
in the world like her i started getting
emails and then decided to start an
online registry
and
so i started learning about families
here and there and
you know we went from a few handful now
we know
something like 500 around the world for
maddie and others like her the future is
unknown scn8a makes part of the door
that connects the inside and the outside
of her brain cells
and so in maddie's case the door is
stuck open
so the kilners treasure their time with
their daughter she's a happy
beautiful girl
and she's so determined
but there's no there's no treatment
now and there's no cure the family has
raised more than 80 thousand dollars for
a first canadian study to help develop
new treatments for scn8a at sickkids
hospital but even more funding is needed
because research could lead to a better
outcome for patients there must be a way
that we can make things better and
that's why we're raising money for the
treatment and for for the study so that
we can help in our way karen lieberman
global news toronto
and that is global national for this
wednesday i'm colleen christie tonight's
york canada is the alberta legislature
in edmonton all decked out there are
beautiful shots all over canada please
email us yours to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching and i hope to see
you again tomorrow take care of
yourselves goodnight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]